wieder ein unwetter wieder eine
flutkatastrophe
wieder überschwemmte straßen die zu
reißenden flüssen werden und diesmal
spielt sich das nicht bei uns im land
sondern ganz im süden italiens sizilien
catania ist diesmal der unglücksort der
katastrophenort dass die stunden nach
dieser schrecklichen flutkatastrophe
ganz im süden italiens also einer
schweren schweren regenfällen diese
bilder und wir wissen in und um catania
herum soll es weiterregnen bis
mindestens morgen noch und das sind
bilder die uns an ahrweiler erinnern und
sich eben diesmal hier abspielen in
einer ohnehin recht schwach
aufgestellten region ganz im südzipfel
europas und genau dorthin gehen wir
jetzt zu unserem bild reporter jörg
völkerling der mittendrin steht in
diesem katastrophengebiet und wir alle
haben die bilder im kopf von ahrweiler
zeigt uns einmal was du im moment in
dieser neuen katastrophenregion ganz im
süden europas erlöst
guten morgen ich wirke vielleicht ein
bisschen deplatziert hier im kurzen hemd
bei sonnenschein dieses diese idylle
trügt ein bisschen denn vor 48 stunden
standen wir hier sozusagen wirklich im
auge des orkans wir können hier mal
hinter uns gucken das ist die via thea
und die ist ein bisschen abschüssig und
von oben sind hier wirklich innerhalb
von minuten die wassermassen der flüsse
der umliegenden flüsse herr abgeschossen
teilweise stand das wasser bis zu einen
meter hoch in tiefer gelegenen plätzen
ein ganzer fischmarkt das weggespült
wurden autos sind mitgerissen worden
aber so schnell wie die flut und die
wassermassen hier gekommen sind man hat
von bis zu 300 litern auf den
quadratmeter angesprochen ist das wasser
auch wieder verschwunden bin einer
stunde war das wasser wieder weg und
jetzt zwei tage danach sehen wir
eigentlich relativ wenig wie sie im
trockenen straßen aber wir sehen auch in
den hauseingängen überall sandsäcke wir
sehen barrikaden mit denen die wiebe
geschäftsbesitzer versuchen das was
jetzt kommen soll in den nächsten
stunden aus ihren geschäften
fernzuhalten denn das ist die große
gefahr der wetterbericht sagt voraus
dass es noch mal schlimmer werden könnte
als das was hier am dienstag passiert
ist es bewegt sich über dem mittelmeer
ein wie ein zyklon mit teilweise 120 km
h und es ist große frage ob der heute im
laufe des abends an land treffen wird
und einfach noch viel verheerender
überschwemmungen anrichten könnte wir
haben hier in catania einer 300.000
einwohner stadt auf sizilien die
natürlich auch ein touristenziel ist
boxen ausgerechnet eine touristenpaar
aus stolberg bei aachen getroffen also
herbert frank und kirsten schipanski die
selber auch im sommer die flut im aartal
in nordrhein-westfalen miterlebt haben
die den vergleich auch haben wie haben
sie denn am vergangenen dienstag diese
diesen einbruch der wassermassen hier
erlebt können sie uns das schildern ja
das war schon heftig das ging ruckzuck
es hat er den ganzen tag geregnet das
war moderat und dann ging es richtig los
und aus dieser straße wurde dann einer
halben stunde ein reißender fluss
ja wir haben dann gewartet wir kamen
nicht mehr auf die andere straßenseite
wo wir wohnen bis es sich eben beruhigt
hatte aber es war jetzt nicht zu
vergleichen mit den wetterbedingungen
die wir in der eifel erlebt haben vor
ein paar wochen ja nehmen sie das
mahlgut frau schipanski sind an dem tag
sie haben mir eine ferienwohnung ganz in
der nähe sie wollen die insel erkunden
mit bus und bahn und an dem tag waren
sie mit crocs unterwegs sozusagen
sommerlich sowie jetzt gekleidet sind ja
20 grad wie war dann die situation als
das wasser hier hereinbrach wie haben
sie sich dafür halten ja zunächst haben
wir gedacht wir gehen direkt mit cox
weil das zu füßen sollten wir sowieso
bekommen und wir wollten noch ein paar
lebensmittel vorher einkaufen und haben
uns auch regenschirme und eine
regenjacke besorgt ja und als wir dann
anderthalb stunden später vom einkauf
zurück in unsere wohnung wollten mussten
wir wirklich wege suchen um über die
straßen zu kommen teilweise bis über die
knie stand uns das wasser man musste
aufpassen dass man sich nicht verletzt
an heran schwimmenden gegenständen und
scrum kühlschränke und paletten entgegen
ja und das einem auch nicht die füße
weggerissen wurden weil man den
untergrund ja nicht mehr sehen konnten
also dass wir uns dann in einer einfahrt
in einer passage gesichert haben um
abzuwarten was dann passiert ich glaube
wir haben auch gehört es gibt auch ganz
kreative lösungen sozusagen um des
wassers irgendwie das rauszuhalten aus
den geschäften ein pizzabäcker hat pizza
teilgenommen und hat ihn sozusagen in
die fugen gestopft damit das wasser da
nicht eindringen kann aber herr frank
sie haben uns auch geschildert sie haben
sehr dramatisch die kraft dieses wasser
zu spüren bekommen als sie hier gesehen
haben ein auto ist mitgerissen wurden
können sie uns das mal schildern was sie
da beobachtet haben wir haben ja hier in
der antwort gestanden an kleinen das
auto parkt er dagegen über an diesem
kiosk und die wassermengen wurden immer
kräftiger und dann wird das auto
weggetragen und schlug da hinten auf
diesen kübel auf und blieb da hängen und
dann ging das so hoch dass es über die
motorhaube schoss und dann haben mehrere
leute versucht die frau die in dem auto
nach saß aber die tür nicht mehr auf
bekam die raus zu bekommen haben dann
pullover aneinander gebunden um das eine
kette zu machen um sich zusichern
dass diese puffer sind dann wohl
gerissen aber die haben die frau
irgendwann raus bekommen gott sei dank
gott sei dank ja zwei todesopfer sind
bisher dennoch zu beklagen und die große
hoffnung in sizilien ist dass es nicht
noch mehr werden und dass diese
unwetterlage dann übers wochenende
spätestens ab kriegen